these pictures filmed on the helmet
camera of a member of the Dover Lifeboat
crew Show the recent Rescue of five
people in the channel they all made it
safely to shore but they're joining an
asylum system which is buckling and
costing Millions a day in accommodation
alone according to information revealed
by the Home Affairs select committee so
a vast number of people are still not
knowing if their claim is going to be
successful or not and are residing in
the UK at taxpayers expense
yes they will be at different stages so
some may be pending their appeal but
they're as as is well documented I think
in the statistics there is a challenge
in processing uh Asylum claims in a
timely way at present every day 5.6
million pounds is being spent on hotels
for Asylum Seekers that's on top of 1.2
million on housing for Afghan refugees
evacuated after the fall of the Taliban
so far this year 38 000 people have
crossed the channel in small boats
compared with 28 and a half thousand in
the whole of last year that figure
includes 12 000 albanians mostly single
adult men compared to 50 in 2020
with so many migrant arrivals the
committee heard manston airport
processing site in Kent described as
unsafe because of over capacity it's a
really dangerous
situation it's not it's failing to
address vulnerability there are risks
there in terms of fire in terms of
disorder in terms of you know medical
and infection
the home office has processed just four
percent of Asylum claims from migrants
who crossed the channel last year the
new home secretary Sue Ella bravaman has
been talking tough on migration but all
this shows what a huge challenge she
faces as the country counts every penny
in public spending in a cost of living
crisis he solid Sky News